[Música]
y tan solo minutos antes de que
terminara su mandato como la alta
comisionada a los derechos humanos de la
onu michele bachelet publicó el reporte
sobre la situación de la minoría de los
uigures en la región autónoma de
xinjiang en china desde 2017 en su
oficina recibió denuncias de detenciones
arbitrarias de las autoridades chinas
contra dichos o musulmanes señalaban
además que los torturaban en los centros
de detención y que a las mujeres las
obligaban a abortar y que las esteriliza
van forzosamente en septiembre del año
2018 bachelet dijo que quería ir a
xinjiang pero china prolongó la
realización de dicha visita ya fue en
septiembre del 21 que la oficina sostuvo
que ya estaba terminando entonces el
reporte sobre la situación de los
derechos humanos en esa región autónoma
y aunque en diciembre de ese mismo año
reiteró que lo publicaría solo lo reveló
hasta el día de ayer además bachelet
viajó en mayo de 2022 a china por
primera vez en 17 años esto para un alto
comisionado de la onu para los derechos
humanos analizamos entonces este tema y
saludamos a carlos veríssimo es
para ser experto en temas de china
gracias por estar con nosotros carlos en
directo américa de france 24 este
reporte concluye que el gobierno chino
entonces podría haber cometido crímenes
de lesa humanidad contra los uigures qué
implicaciones tiene esto para el gigante
asiático
raúl buendía si realmente es un informe
valiente por así decirlo por parte de la
alta comisionada para naciones unidas
no lo desmerece que se haya presentado
unos minutos antes o un tiempo antes de
que ella se vaya este naturalmente
sufrió muchísimas presiones no sólo de
china sino de algunos países que
acompañaron este tipo de posición y en
definitiva lo que hace es plasmar
por primera vez
con una energía importante a nivel
internacional como puede ser la
organización de naciones unidas
algo que se viene dándole hace mucho
tiempo y que nosotros mismos saca en
france24 y justamente contigo ya lo
habíamos cubierto con anterioridad los
problemas que existen dentro de china en
especial con una de las etnias que
integran esa población y que sufre una
persecución de carácter naturalmente
político no podemos pensar de que china
diga que hay un millón de sediciosos en
la etnia uigur una etnia de 10 millones
de personas que son los que sufren hoy
este tipo de reacción por parte del
gobierno de pekín o beijing claro carlos
es también en digamos china respondió a
este informe rechazando lo por supuesto
un informe de casi tres veces más
grandes que el que publicó la onu en el
que enfatiza su lucha contra el
terrorismo y también digamos la
protección de alguna manera lo que ellos
llaman los derechos humanos cuáles son
esas políticas de la región de xinjiang
y por qué la onu pone los ojos sobre
esta región cuál es la realidad de los
uigures
muy bien muy buena pregunta
hoy en la etnia está sufriendo además no
sólo
lo que serían los centros de reeducación
o los centros de trabajo que es muy
importante deberse a otra parte que no
está plasmada del todo sino centros
donde donde trabajaban los figuras
jornadas larguísimas niños mujeres
embarazadas etcétera
la región está sufriendo una
intervención por parte de gobierno chino
donde cada uno de ellos no puede plasmar
ni su cultura ni su religión ni su forma
de vida sino que tienen que dar cuenta
casi de todos sus movimientos oficiales
de cumplimiento del gobierno chino que
están establecidos en la zona la zona
está intervenida totalmente por por
pekín
y de alguna forma todos tienen que dar
cuenta de lo que serían sus relaciones
de vida y fundamentalmente su trabajo la
etnia y fundamentalmente los sus líderes
en estos casos se une la religión a los
líderes de carácter étnico por así decir
sufren
separación son exiliados dentro de china
o sea son arrancados de su lugar de
nacimiento son trasladados de una ciudad
a otra realmente lo que se escapa lo que
está sucediendo en xinjiang es algo que
llama poderosamente la atención lo que
es lo que ocurrió en hace pocas horas es
algo que hace que el mundo libre y
fundamentalmente los analistas
internacionales estén satisfechos de
algo que realmente va a cambiar la lo
que sería el punto de vista de como
china maneja sus relaciones humanas y
las relaciones sociales es informe
serviría a carlos para que china cambie
esas políticas para que no se cometan
violaciones a los derechos humanos o
crímenes de lesa humanidad como bien lo
dijo bachelet además que están un tema
bien importante porque si bien es cierto
que ese informe es el contundente como
bien lo estamos conversando en contra el
gobierno chino en contra de esta minoría
musulmana uigur organizaciones
internacionales también defensoras de
los derechos humanos han dicho que
bachelet ha sido un poco blanda no al
tratar este tema que tan blanda ha sido
bachelet y porque él atitlán de tener
una política blanda en respecto a la
china
es que es que muchos de nosotros con la
visita de bachelet en mayo del 2022
vimos que de alguna forma ella no hacía
una presión importante y pensamos que
esto nunca se va a presentar realmente a
partir de esta presentación creo que el
mundo libre y las organizaciones
sociales han quedado satisfechas por lo
que ha sucedido se ha puesto en él
en la prensa lo que sucede en china a la
otra parte de la pregunta realmente el
tema de dar difusión a lo que ha
sucedido de la etnia uigur ha cambiado y
ha mejorado para ellos sustancialmente
el 2017 en adelante hasta el 2019
teníamos los campos de reeducación o los
campos de educación de a poco chinas a
rosales de desactualizado no los los ha
llenado no no los ha colmado como los
tenía anteriormente y los suns han
desarmado eso ya es un avance para todo
esto siempre que el mundo de alguna
forma se queje por los derechos humanos
porque haga esto no es por eeuu o por
sino que el mundo tiene que intentar
cuidar los derechos humanos a nivel
global este logra avance por eso es tan
importante la difusión es tan importante
de lo que ustedes también hacen en este
caso carlos sabe también ese habla de
posibles tensiones entre las relaciones
comerciales sobre todo entre estados
unidos y china estos podría presentar
tras este informe la revelación del
informe
con las primeras denuncias de campos de
reeducación y campos de trabajos
forzados ya vimos que el mundo
occidental o el mundo libre empezó a
cuestionar las compras fundamentalmente
lo que era ropa que era y algunos
tejidos que estaban siendo hechos en
esas fábricas y en definitiva eso es lo
que china más a lo que quiera más le
tiene miedo el problema de pérdida de
mercados chinas está tiene uno de los
parámetros más importantes de intentar
la estabilidad a nivel global y no
quiere ningún tipo de problema que le
pueda generar algún cierre de mercado o
merma en sus mercados con eso ha perdido
hoy en europa es una realidad
las grandes cantidades de personas que
compraban algunos de sus artefactos que
podían ser supuestamente hechos en estos
campos para mí y para muchos analistas
ese es el punto más importante de todo
esto cuando china ve que esto puede ser
en desmedro de algunas situaciones
fundamentalmente comerciales y
económicas en este caso de mercado toma
acciones que puedan de alguna forma
compensarse en este caso son acciones
que van a beneficiar muchísimo
a esta etnia que tiene el derecho de ser
libre y expresar su cultura